[Music]
on November 18th 1928 Mickey Mouse was
introduced to the world in the film
Steamboat Willie but this may be one of
the last birthdays Mickey celebrates as
the intellectual property of Disney
copyrights for the popular character are
set to expire on January 1st 2024 Mickey
might have become public property sooner
except that each time the copyright on
Steamboat Willie was set to lapse Disney
and others pushed Congress to lengthen
US copyright terms by 1998 works of
corporate authorship were exclusive
company property for 95 years from
publication but this time around there
doesn't seem to be any serious effort to
extend Disney's copyright for several
reasons first each version of Mickey
Mouse as a separate copyright so only
the Steamboat Willie version will enter
the public domain in 2024 second Disney
has clearly diversified its stable of
copyrighted characters third copyright
activists have out organized Hollywood
and for if it's unlikely the public
would accept the copyright extension
beyond 95 years so enjoy your day Mickey
because soon you will belong to your
adoring public what do you think will
Disney let its copyrights on Mickey
expire let us know in our poll also let
us know what other topics you'd like our
scholars to cover in 60 seconds and be
sure to LIKE and subscribe for more
research and videos from AEI